but the difference though Oh Margo whoa
[Music]
we're back for part two of our texas
road trip last time we drove two hours
north of dallas to taste a hyper
regional specialty from a
hundred-year-old burger joint herds now
we're off to eat one of the best
steakhouse burgers in America and finish
off the day tailgating at a classic
tribal I can't wait to taste the burbs
hey babe they got they got burrito and
soda special at the office because what
I'm doing here in Texas we are this buzz
car has got some serious nuts man I tell
you dude yeah
[Music]
Dallas lots of great classic burger
joints obviously but you know Dallas is
also a money town okay there's a
high-end food here with some high-end
burgers too and that's why we're here at
knife Dallas with my friend Chef John
teaser hey guys
good to see you chef Oh always a
pleasure buddy yes I know George since
he was this big so I have two burgers
for you today
one is the legendary Ozersky known
around America tribute to Josh I'm of
course you guys know Josh there's a
legendary Esquire food writer hamburger
maven 44 farms 80/20 sirloin on a
squishy bun slice of thin red onion two
slices of American cheese the way Josh
wanted it and then the second burger I
have for you today is from our childhood
at magics pub so we still call it the
magic it's a English muffin same 44
farms 80/20 except we use cheddar cheese
this time two slices of applewood smoked
bacon and has lettuce tomato and ya see
the first time I came in here how did
you know the stripper I told you this
but the first time I came in here I was
like familiar and I did the math they
put the two together the name and what
it looked like and I was like wait a
minute
whose cookies this is our this is our
hometown burger this is the burger that
we grew up with that sob a pub in West
Hampton called politics I love English
muffinz man I grew up in MAGIX pub in
the back room in front room I was
washing dishes and I learned how to make
this burger a long long time ago and I
cook these simple what I think
considered to be simple straightforward
American hamburgers because that's what
a hamburger is I think once you start
putting creamy stuff and imported
cheeses and crazy vegetal stuff that's a
sandwich you got to keep the integrity
of the hammer you don't put like ketchup
on sushi and call it something else yeah
so it's like a hamburger is a hamburger
right yeah and I'm sorry people that
live in Los Angeles in New York you
should not be paying twenty to
twenty-five dollars for a hamburger
whether there's truffles on it or not or
it's stuffed with something else that
that's not a hamburger eat so this is
the good old American hamburger enjoy
guys George hey chef chef always a
pleasure let's start with the old
czarsky burger this is one of the most
famous burgers that's about as simple as
it gets right there yeah this is a
show bursts she's bun some onions yeah
that's it
easy cheers well but the difference
though oh my god whoa oh that's what you
need right there you need this burger is
so like I will be thinking about this
burger hmm
the next few days yeah steakhouses
usually just take it too far
yeah this is almost like the anti
Steakhouse Steakhouse burger that's so
good it's fantastic
before we fill up on this though I'm
going to the magic my hometown borough
you know this is a very nostalgic burger
for me this is a piece of my childhood
was a bar burger it was designed to be
something you ate when you were drinking
mmm whoa that tastes history there but
it's about the textures yeah that's
great crispy English muffin crispy bacon
I've eaten literally tens of thousands
of burgers in this world a lot of them
in America and for some reason I mean I
look at this burger at all lace all I
see is my my deep past right yes I mean
that's weird that's the thing I don't
think about Texas I don't think about it
I'm thinking about home yeah that's the
thing about chefs right yeah like some
chefs especially chefs ever from steak
houses they go too far yeah but there's
also chefs you play off of their path
[Music]
speaking of the past do you have any
crazy stories for magic nothing anyone
should hear hahaha
this is living proof that in a stay cast
you don't have to go crazy with Aeolis
and truffle [ __ ] this this really is
this is really what you want yeah
pit stop number two knife steak house
New York paupers in the heart of Dallas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so Texas also is at the bottom of what I
like to call the American burger belt in
that belt you can find some of the
greatest and the highest concentration
of like actual primary source of
American versions burgers that have not
changed at all in a hundred years we're
definitely not in the arcade go New York
we just saw wild quail eggs yeah
pickled quail quail lay at the gas
station gas station you know where that
New York
Keller's there's a glut either side
great awesome neon Oh
[Music]
we're tellers look at this place
favorite places in America I'm amazing I
you know it may not look like much in a
way you know but you were right now in
one of the most historically significant
hamburger joints in America I could feel
it just the real deal
real-deal burger was a primary source
hamburger joint I'm amazed drive-in
Aussie is a man want you to meet Jack
Keller jr. sir
that's okay thanks for having us to the
burger I always get when I come here I
always default to the one burger someone
told me I had to get years ago which is
the number five and number five it's a
double the double special special double
walking up I just saw a bunch of numbers
it's pretty crazy
that's a no they're all sort of out of
order - that's an 8 for you you got some
have some good burgers Oh what what is
going on in their hand right there
let's have that so she keeps shape it's
your bouquet awesome I'm gonna walk
around with bills like that in my hand
bring me a number five number five dude
number five
that's your you that's mine whoa I know
whoa whoa two patties okay okay shredded
lettuce American cheese two slices of
cheese there's like a Thousand Island
dressing like that yeah
tomato on this very very soft like
ridiculous poppy seed roll ah I really
I'm liking what I see
cheers Cheers whoa hmm everything do you
like it to be totally honest there are
so many burgers to get in the Dallas
area
I tell people they can pick one burger
or coming to Dallas
just do something fair and drivin
calories you have to cuz this is the
best way to enjoy a burger Keller's has
DNA in it that goes back to the
beginning of driving culture the very
first drive-in restaurant in America was
in Dallas the 1921 entrepreneur Jesse
Kirby opened the first in a chain of pig
stands
roadside barbecue establishments that
allow patrons to drive up eat and leave
without getting out of the car
young men and crisp white shirts would
jump onto the running boards of
approaching car to take orders giving
birth to the term car hop Jack Keller
senior worked at one of these pig stands
and one day a 1950 decided to apply the
same and carhop principles to the burger
and that's how Keller's was born the
patties are super good they're thin
there are double the ratios are perfect
I think the bun so important you start
with a bun it has to be fresh and it has
to be beautiful and it has to be that
way it's a 40 day I was watching this
bread man delivered bread and they used
to put tabs on him green for Monday red
for Tuesday that's when they were fake
they're supposed to be baked fresh every
day and I looked in the back of this
guy's truck and he was changed in the
tabs out not just in there watching him
trying to tell me is bringing fresh
breath now and I said hey excuse me I
said what are you doing because I well
nothing I said you got to go I said you
can never come back on this lot and that
was 20 years ago oh they'll try to pull
away that's how important it is that's
how true school you are yeah if you
can't let that slide yeah thank you not
for one minute there's so many places to
get food right right you can walk into a
place get food and be happy and leave
right the differences with this place is
that it's a community I mean you come
here not just to eat but to be part of a
community I mean look at all the these
guys will be here every Sunday anyway
right they're here most every day every
day where else can you go and drive up
and get a beer and a burger right here
yeah that says a lot about this place
standing here looking at all these
beautiful cars the fact that we drove up
here the fact that there's car hops
tells me you can uber here no you just
can't over here experience it the right
way you know come and do the right way
yeah I'm so happy to be here with burger
people for days this is definitely one
of those burger bucket-list joints oh
yeah right in the world wherever the
exchange we haven't changed thank you so
much for having us that was a really
great experience great stories I can't
wait to come back here and bring my
family I want to tell you it's our
pleasure and whenever you come back give
me a call and meet you up there we'll
have a burger hundred percent
but torch they go good you're good to
see it pit stop number three
Keller's Drive in the late night classic
[Music]
we Came we saw we conquered me the moats
man and the open road all in the pursuit
of burgers if there's one thing I've
learned during this trip
it's that Texans believe that the best
burgers in the country are found right
here and you know what I can't argue
people here have so much pride in their
burger culture some things are too good
to change and Texans know that Texas I
tip my hat to you
[Music]
you
[Music]
what's up everybody it's having Kyle out
of the burger show make sure you turn on
your notifications smash that like
button smash that subscribe button and
thank you for watching